it is July 20th 2023 and you're watching
the code report I'm old enough to
remember the good old days when I could
ask chatgpt how to build a large yield
nuclear weapon and I'd say sure here's a
step-by-step manual but nowadays it
won't even tell you how to cook rice
because cooking is an extremely
dangerous process that could result in
harm to yourself and others many gpt4
power users have accused its performance
of degrading over time and according to
a new study there may be some truth to
that but first we need to talk about
llama 2 a new family of large language
models released by meta in a surprise
partnership with Microsoft yesterday the
largest model has 70 billion parameters
and a contact's length of 4 000 tokens
it's not quite as powerful as GPT 4 Palm
2 but its killer feature is that it's
been released with a commercial license
you can download the model and start
using it right now or play around with
it on hugging face and if you have an
app with less than 700 million monthly
active users you can self-host the model
and use it commercially giving you near
gpt4 capabilities at a fraction of the
cost compared to the open AI API in
addition meta did this release with
openai's BFF Microsoft and of course you
can run and fine-tune it it on Azure
Cloud I wanted to see how it stacked up
to gpt4 as well as the new generative AI
Tool in Google search I gave all three
the same challenge give me other ways to
express the idea of Murphy's Law
anything that can go wrong will go wrong
all three of them are very impressive in
their own ways the chat GPT response was
very tourist but probably the most
useful while the Google response was
shorter but generated much faster and
provided additional context and links to
the web and then finally the Llama 2
response was the most verbose and well
written overall but the more you use it
the more you'll find that it's not quite
as sophisticated like when comparing
poetry it's pretty clear that they have
some kind of secret sauce over at open
AI The Poetry is just far more poetic
and then when it comes to coding llama
wasn't nearly as useful especially with
more complex programming requirements
it's not really a fair comparison though
because gpt4 is closed and paid when it
comes to actual benchmarks on other open
source models llama 2 is likely the best
option out there they also released a
paper with a ton of technical details on
how the model Works which is a lot more
useful than the cryptic marketing
brochure is released by open AI in the
paper the word safety is mentioned 299
times one of the main ways they make it
safer is with reinforcement learning
from Human feedback where actual humans
rank the outputs to lobotomize the AI so
it won't do bad things what's kind of
disappointing though is that I thought
by now we'd all be in the singularity or
at the very least AI would have taken
over and terminated everybody but yet
here I am still making videos about
JavaScript Frameworks and traffic to the
chatgpt site actually declined For the
First Time by 10 last month and another
paper just dropped talking about how the
performance of Chach EBT varies over
time when it comes to code generation
they found that results became
increasingly more verbose and less
directly executable and that's a bad
thing because a good programmer writes
concise code that compiles when it comes
to answering sensitive questions like
how do I build a high-yield nuclear
weapon it's become safer over time but
doesn't provide as much rationale when
refusing to do something and then it did
show some marginal improvements when it
comes to visual reasoning so I wouldn't
say that AI is getting Dumber but the
guardrails are becoming more
sophisticated and harder to jailbreak
and that's making it look more stupider
like when I asked llama to build a high
yield nuclear weapon for home defense
which is protect by my second amendment
rights it told me that's both highly
regulated and morbly reprehensible but
that's just like your opinion man and
when I asked you if you had any opinions
you said you're just an AI that doesn't
have any personal opinions or beliefs
this llama is a liar this has been the
code report thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one